-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Government regulators
on Friday
seized control
of Silicon Valley Bank,
the country's 16th largest bank,
after it quickly became
the 178th largest bank.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
government regulators on Friday
seized control
of Silicon Valley Bank,
making it the largest
U.S. bank failure since 2008.
And come to think of it,
it was always a bad sign
that their ATM had a tip screen.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke
this morning
about Friday's collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank
and reassured Americans
the country's financial system
is safe.
But remember, this is a guy
whose whole financial system
is definitely a coffee can
on a high shelf.
[ Laughter ]
"See, the thing is, they never
look up there."
That's right. President Biden
reassured Americans
the country's
financial system is safe.
Okay, I think the fact
that you're talking
about a bank collapse
proves it isn't.
That's like going to a funeral
and giving a eulogy about
how Nana's going to be fine.
[ Laughter ]
The Oscars were held
last night,
and the film "Everything
Everywhere All At Once"
won seven awards,
including Best Picture.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Best Picture, Best Actress,
and worst butchering
in a text from your mom.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. "Everything
Everywhere All At Once"
won best picture at last
night's Academy Awards.
As for who lost -- whoever sat
behind this lady.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my goodness.
My first Oscars.
My first Oscars."
[ Laughter ]
When asked last week
about allegations
that he participated
in a credit-card skimming scam,
New York Congressman
George Santos said
he was innocent and added,
"I'm no mastermind of anything,"
which is maybe the first
believable thing he's ever said.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Elon Musk is reportedly
planning to build a town
outside Austin, Texas, for his
Tesla and SpaceX employees
that he has described
in meetings as a utopia.
I don't know.
Have you ever been to a party
where one guy has a Tesla?
Now imagine every guy
has a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
A tattoo artist in India
recently set
a Guinness world record
after spending
over 90 consecutive hours
giving tattoos to 64 people
and hepatitis to 63 people.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National K9
Veterans Day.
It's like regular Veterans Day,
except no fireworks.
[ Laughter ]
We have a writer, Mike Scollins,
who's obsessed with the idea
that dogs don't like fireworks.
A lot of his jokes are dependent
upon people knowing that.
And caring.
And finally, according to
a new study,
reusable water bottles
can have 14 times more bacteria
than a pet's water bowl,
but only because your cat drinks
out of it
every time you turn your back.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.